the world of Aquaman is so big it wants
us to visit all these new kingdoms and
meet all these interesting new different
characters there's a lot of new worlds
that we're creating it's very much
larger than life it's just full-fledged
fantasy the glory of this movie is the
spectacle the color and the
visuals it is this globe tring Adventure
that Jason and I have
one of the coolest things about Aquaman
is because it takes place underwater
there's so much
unknown they end up discovering a
massive wall the lost
kingdom it's ancient and very
tough where these monstrous
creatures there is nothing that I've
ever been a part of that's like this you
have the these characters that you can
relate to that you can identify with you
can take them on this weird and crazy
journey to all these different strange
worlds it's always fun to watch James
make something on this level and I'm
always like I don't know how you're
doing it man he makes massive massive
movies blows me
away it really fires up people's
imagination and makes them want to go on
this magical
journey if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
follow